GREG NEISWANDER:
My name is Greg.
I'm a researcher at Google,
and I work for the Android Auto
project.
GERMAN BAUER: And
I'm German Bauer.
I'm a designer on the
Android Auto team.
How are you guys doing?
GREG NEISWANDER: And
we're going to talk
about designing for driving.
So German will explain
what that actually means.
GERMAN BAUER: So
what we want to do
is we want to give you a
little bit of an insight of how
Android Auto came about,
the considerations that
went into making it, and how
we're supporting developers
who might not know even about
automotive design in bringing
their Android up to
this new platform.
And then, time
permitting, we want
to talk a little bit
about the future as well.
GREG NEISWANDER:
So Android Auto--
does everybody know what it is?
Anybody not know what it is?
I think everybody knows.
But for those that don't know,
it's an extension of Android,
bringing Android into
the car so that you
get the apps, the functionality,
the features that you want
from your phone, but you have
it presented in a new manner
that's fit for the
context of driving.
GERMAN BAUER: Why are we in
an automotive area as well?
If you heard
[? Sunda ?] this morning
talk about the whole
larger platform of Android,
we're really a big part of that.
Android is all about
having many touch points
into people's lives across
devices-- not just phones, not
just tablets, but also
watches, cars, and TV.
And this is all for
over a billion users
and a whole ecosystem
on top of it
that new developers
help us build as well.
And together, we make
it a really big thing.
And as of today,
at I/O 2016, we're
talking about Android Auto
itself becoming a platform that
has two new form
factors in addition
to what was already on the
market for about a year,
spanning a wider range
of automotive types
and actually really
becoming a system on itself.
And the first one,
the first form factor
I want to talk about is
the one that we already
saw in the photo,
which is by plugging
a phone into a
compatible car, and then
your phone becomes projected
directly onto the car's display
and you use the car's control
to interact with your content.
And so the phone is powering
the entire experience
in this form factor.
And as of I/O 2016, as
of today, Android Auto
is also previewing a
brand new form factor
for those cars that are not
yet compatible with the plugged
in version of Android.
So we're extending
into these older cars.
For example, if
you have a classic
and you want to
put Bluetooth in,
this is a great Android
audio experience directly
on the phone screen.
So you don't need
anything else there.
And the third thing
we want to preview
is really a concept of Android
as an embedded platform built
directly into the car.
You can see this outside
in the red Maserati.
There's a preview of
that concept there.
And it's that car
manufacturers can actually
build their native
system on top of Android.
And so you can get a great
experience directly built
into the car.
And what we're super-thrilled
to see, having built the system,
is finally realizing this
bigger vision of Android Auto
running across all these
different platforms
and translating the UI,
depending on the screen form
factor, depending on the
input devices that you have.
And I think this is
something that we are super
excited about.
And Greg is now
shedding more light
on why driving is really
so different than using
a regular phone in
a regular context.
GREG NEISWANDER: Right.
So when we move into
new spaces, it's
really important to take the
context of the environment
into account.
When we look at
driving today, we
see that we're spending a
lot of time inside the car.
So from a fairly
recent study, they
found that the average
person in the US
spends around 45 minutes
inside the car per day.
For those of us living
in the Bay Area,
it's actually probably higher,
given the traffic volumes
that we have out here.
But either way, that's
somewhere on the magnitude
of around 280 hours per
year inside the car.
It's a lot of time.
And it's a piece of our life.
And what we find is
that during that time,
people don't want to necessarily
stop their digital life.
So they want to still be
able to be entertained.
They want to communicate.
They want to be productive.
And if we can't figure
out the right way
to convey the information,
then it leads to problems.
So as an example,
texting-- we all
know that texting isn't good.
A study found that, or they
noted at highway speeds,
when you text and drive,
it's approximately
equivalent to driving the
length of a football field
while not looking
at the roadway.
So it's not good.
And we know that
we shouldn't do it,
yet we also know that
people are still doing it.
So the question is why?
Well, one reason is that we
tend to overestimate our driving
abilities.
So as drivers, we're
generally overconfident.
And we tend to try and we don't
understand the true dangers.
So basically,
we're overconfident
with our abilities.
And we also underestimate
the true dangers of driving.
This leads to a pretty
bad mix, because when
we want to engage
with-- when we want
to be productive or
communicate or be entertained,
it means that we start
to engage with our phone
or do things that we
shouldn't necessarily do.
And the problem is,
when we're driving,
if we screw up, if you
do something stupid,
you don't just put
yourself at risk,
but you put all the others
in the car with you at risk.
And you put those around
you at risk as well.
So it's really
critical that we figure
out how can we
re-examine the technology
to better suit the environment.
GERMAN BAUER: Didn't you
in fact have a statistic
where you said that
the majority of drivers
think they're better
than average drivers?
Which is actually
mathematically impossible.
GREG NEISWANDER: Yeah,
it was somewhere around--
I think it was 93%
of those sampled
thought they were
above average drivers.
GERMAN BAUER: And
the rest was probably
a statistics expert that
realized that wasn't possible.
So from this point, it's
really, really clear
that designing for the
phone is not the same thing
as designing for driving.
Really two different things.
I think Greg has made abundantly
clear with the three points
that he just made that it's
a very different situation.
And this different
environment needs
to be thought of as
such when we start
about designing absent
services for this environment.
GREG NEISWANDER: Right.
And one thing to note is it's
not mostly the phone's fault.
If you go into a
car dealership today
and you look at the technology
that's going inside the car,
a lot of them resemble
tablets and phones right now.
So it's not just
for the technology,
but again it's the way
that the information
is constructed and
ultimately conveyed
that's the critical elements.
GERMAN BAUER: And so for
Android Auto-- and this
is what this talk is
about-- the experience
needs to be designed
specifically for driving.
And what this means,
we're going to start
with the next few slides.
So for one thing, one easy
way that we can think of this
is that really, driving and
keeping your eyes on the road
is task number one.
And dealing with the phone
should be task number two.
And this is very different than
phones, where we design apps
specifically for
whole engagement,
for full engagement.
And here, we actually
want to do it differently,
because we don't want you
to spend this much time
with your eyes off the road.
GREG NEISWANDER: Right.
And another way to
think about this
is if you substitute
primary task for driving
and your secondary
task is a distraction.
So all other activities
inside the car
that don't pertain to driving
are, in fact, distracting.
And we find that people engage
in distracting activities
quite a lot.
So there's a recent study that
looked at naturalistic driving
data and found that
over 50% of the time,
people engaged in
distracting activities.
This can be anything
from texting,
as we talked about
before, but it can also
be eating or conversing
with a passenger
or even dancing
in your car seat.
So all of this, if it
doesn't pertain to driving,
it has some element of
distraction for the driving
task.
When we look at
distraction itself,
we can break it down from
the human perspective.
And we see that
ultimately, it can
be thought of in three
main fundamental ways.
So we have visual distraction.
This is, of course, when
your eyes are off the road,
looking at other things.
We can have manual
distraction, and this
is when your hands are
off the steering wheel
or off steering controls,
fidgeting with other things,
like the climate control.
Then we can have
cognitive distraction.
This one's a little
bit harder to assess,
but it's basically when
your mind is not actively
thinking about the
driving task and is
attending to other things.
In the real world,
we rarely see a task
that takes just one
form of distraction.
Most often, tasks
have some element
of all of these
types of distraction.
So if we use an
example, something
as simple as rolling
up the window.
In order to determine if you
need to roll up the window,
you might have to
glance at the window.
So there's some visual.
You have to reach over
to the button, of course.
So there's some
manual distraction.
And then you have to
think about maybe,
do I need to push or do
I need to pull on it?
So this is a really
simplified example.
And of course, the
levels of distraction
here aren't really critical.
But it's a good
representation, and it
helps us to understand when
we're designing experiences,
we need to figure out how
can we focus the experience,
and how do the
experiences affect
each of the different
channels of distraction.
Ultimately, how can we minimize
the overall distraction?
And what we know is that we
can't fully eliminate it.
Distraction is
always going to exist
in some form inside the car.
But what we can do
is we can mitigate it
through responsible design.
GERMAN BAUER: So then,
how do we fundamentally
rethink how we design
the UI for driving away
from the interaction model
that we know from the handheld?
And what I want to
do is actually share
a few principles
with you that have
come about as we did
a lot of research
and a lot of design iterations,
and let's talk about those.
So one simple
principle that is one
of the foundations
for Android Auto
is that we're really trying
to bias things towards action.
What does this mean?
So when you're on your phone
and you're trying to play music,
for example, you have a
selection of multiple apps.
You select your app.
Then you have maybe a grid of
different suggested things.
The song you have
might not be in there.
You are scrolling down a list,
maybe possibly another list.
And that's a lot of
noodling before you actually
get to play a song.
Compare this with the
old style auto radio,
if you still remember
those from way back when,
where you just press any of the
buttons and out comes music.
It's really simple, or you
put in a CD or cassette
and it just works.
And this is sort of the
gold standard in some ways,
because there's very
little load on you.
You just start it and it
is immediately actionable,
immediately set up
for consumption.
And then you can still change
from there, the channel
or whatever, but it just gives
you some instant gratification.
GREG NEISWANDER: Right.
And then we also want to try
and reduce visual and cognitive
load by overall
simplifying the interface,
making layouts and
content predictable,
so making things consistent, and
then flattening the hierarchies
as much as we can to, , again,
surface actions as quickly
as possible.
So this really overall just
means a reduction in complexity
and really focusing on core
activities that makes sense
to do while driving.
And keep in mind for
other activities,
those can always be deferred
to pre- or post-drive states,
such as playing with settings.
All of this is done to keep
interactions efficient so
that you can get the
content you want,
but then get to drive back to
driving as quickly as possible.
And for those other
tasks, where you're
looking for very
specific content,
voice can be a
great shortcut that
can be this great deep dive.
So if you're looking
for that one song
that you really
want to play, you
can simply make a voice command.
And this allows
you to reroute away
from the complexity of going
through an interface visually
and just make a simple
voice command and get it.
So we really want to enable
voice in all of our apps
so that users can take
advantage of these shortcuts.
And the great thing
is about voice
is it really doesn't
require any visual elements
or manual elements
for distraction.
We're also talking today, if you
go over to the booth later on,
you'll see that we're
working on hot wording
so that OK Google
will work in the car
so that you don't actually
have to press a button
as well to start
your voice session.
Now, the other side of this
is, though we can alleviate
visual and manual
distraction, we
do have to be aware that
voice comes at a cost
through cognitive distraction.
Because every time you think
about what you're going to say,
every time you start to speak,
and every time you listen,
it takes some element
of cognitive processing.
So we want to carefully
design the voice interfaces
and the voice flows to try and
mitigate cognitive processing
and overall cognitive load.
GERMAN BAUER: So
people ask us often,
why don't you just
use your phone?
People are using it today, and
the phone in the last 10 years
has really evolved
to almost like
a competing platform
with smartphones,
and it really hasn't had a
long time to optimize its UI.
But think about it--
when you're driving,
your attention is
primarily on the road.
And your phone will be an
arm's length away from you,
not close to you.
And then finally, if
you've ever driven
on the American
highways around here,
you know there's
a ton of potholes.
And you know what that does
to your touch accuracy.
Have you ever tried
those on a screen?
It's very, very tricky.
And then you throw in
non-ideal lighting conditions
like today, when the car turns,
the light comes from this side,
then from this side.
Sometimes the phone
is full of glare
and you can't
really see anything
and you can't change
any of these things.
And so it becomes clear that
we don't have a regular handset
situation here.
So first of all,
the typography needs
to be significantly larger
to see at a distance.
The touch targets need to be
much more forgiving and bigger.
And then finally,
the contrast needs
to be maximized to work in
all the lighting conditions,
including night driving.
The good news is, with
every building block
that we're making for
the OS, we're also
keeping the developers in
mind as we're building this,
so you don't have to necessarily
spread all these details.
You don't have to be
car and driving experts
as you're building an
app for Android Auto.
So a few examples
are on the left side,
we have font styles that
have been extensively tested
and optimized for
driving use case
that developers can call upon.
We have layouts
in component sizes
built for automotive
touch target sizes.
So all of our
layouts are actually
built on this metric that allows
for these large enough touch
targets.
And then finally, we have
this icon contrast switch-on
mechanism built into
the system where
you can provide an icon as an
app developer that's one color.
And then we switch
the color accordingly
to what happens
with the background.
And this happens automatically.
You don't have to
worry about that.
GREG NEISWANDER: Yes,
so the whole field
of legibility in
glanceable environments
is actually a super,
super interesting area.
And what you find is
that little tweaks
and things like font weight
or font size or contrast
can actually have quite
significant impact
on the overall
readability and time
it takes to understand
or read text.
And so when we're
talking about driving,
we're not talking about
a matter of seconds.
We're really talking a
matter of milliseconds here,
and every little bit counts.
So we're really interested
in this type of research.
MIT Age Lab and
Monotype have both
been conducting research in this
area for quite some time now.
And so we're
collaborating with them
to conduct collaborative
research to, again, investigate
these areas of font legibility,
dynamic lighting environments,
font colors, contrast, font
size, all of these things
to better understand
basically, how
does this really affect
legibility in a driving
context, and how can we
further optimize our system
to, again, even if it's
shaving milliseconds off,
let's make those improvements
and make driving better.
GERMAN BAUER: One of the big
learnings that we had over time
was that we understood
that we needed
to make our system throughout
knowable and familiar
throughout all its applications.
What does this mean?
Well, remember how
Greg previously
talked about cognitive load.
And one of the biggest
loads is actually
what we refer to as mental
loading and unloading
of an application model.
So that basically
refers to the user
as they're switching
from one app to another.
They need to learn and
relearn a new model.
Sometimes they
remember it, of course,
when they use it frequently.
But there's still learning
and unlearning going on.
And if you're driving, then
your mental capacity is already
sort of shrunk because
your attention,
again, is on the road.
And so it means that
for us, it meant
that we wanted the system UI
to organize it in such a way
that the apps are
all self-similar.
There is recognizable
elements in all of the apps
that even if you
switch to another app,
it sort of works
in the same way.
And this is very
different from phones,
obviously, where every app
tries to distinguish itself.
And Spotify has a
completely different UI
than, say, Google Play Music.
But for Android Auto, we want
to keep this at a minimum
so that people don't
have to relearn
in the situation of driving.
So let's look at some
wire frames here.
This is a navigation
application on Android Auto.
And the bioframe is
in the bottom right.
This is the phone application.
You can see the same system
takes place where there
is these recognizable
elements, and we're
going to go through in a second.
And this is an audio
music application, again,
with very, very simple elements.
And in the next
slide, we're going
to talk a little bit about
these common elements that
are used throughout the system.
So we basically designed
the elements in such a way
that they have common
functionality no matter which
app you're in.
And these anchor
points are the menu
on the left top
corner, where you
get access to
alternative content
compared to what you're
currently playing.
The microphone on
the right side,
which accesses what we call
the demand space, which
is basically you can query
the system like a Google Voice
to either do actions or find
a specific piece of content.
Then the application
has its own actions,
and this is the white area.
And the whole system
has an activity strip
at the bottom where
you can switch
between the core activities of
driving, which we identified
as navigation, communication,
audio and music
and entertainment, and then
car-specific activities.
Now let's look at that case
of music application here.
So the first one we saw
was Google Play Music,
and you can see a very
familiar structure
with a play/pause button,
the forward and rewind.
And you have an additional
menu on the right side.
And this here,
this other screen,
is a different application.
This is an audio
app that happens
to have a 30-second rewind
and a 30-second forward.
And even though they
have slightly different
functionality and they
express their brand
in a different color,
it's still fundamentally
the same structure that the
driver can benefit from.
Even if they have never
seen this app before,
they can reuse that.
And when you're at
night, driving at night
has its own specific challenges.
And we do a lot of automatic
switching of some of the panels
and things like that for them
to reduce the overall lighting
intensity.
But you can still recognize
the exact same structure.
And we're actually giving
the application developers
a way to notify them that
when they're in a low light
situation so they can switch
to a different color palette.
This is one of those
things that we're
doing to make it easier
for application developers
so they don't have to redo
everything themselves.
And so today, we're introducing
this new form factor directly
on the phone screen and unifying
the story for the developers
and the overall experience.
Because what you can
see here is exactly
the same structure from
a user experience model,
even though the form
factor is very different
and you may not see as many
buttons in the white area,
because frankly, the
screen is smaller
and is usually in a mount.
But it's exactly the
same structure otherwise.
And this is what this new form
factor looks like, for example,
for Google Play
Music during daytime.
In the next screen, we're
seeing the same application
that we looked at before--
the audio app, which
is right on the next screen.
And again, you recognize the
same structure over and over
again.
And finally at night,
you can see this here.
Again, very similar
building principles.
And even in different
applications like the phone
application, making
a phone call,
this looks immediately
familiar because the actions
are grouped such that the most
important actions are directly
front and center.
And you're immediately
in the experience,
rather than having to navigate
through a bunch of menus
to actually get to the
consumption experience.
And then finally, the
navigation screen,
which is also part
and parcel of this
experience here on the
smaller form factor.
And this functions in
exactly the same way.
GREG NEISWANDER:
Then we also want
to try and be naturally
integrated into the car.
So what does that mean, exactly?
It means that we
want to use existing
buttons for common
functions when we can.
So that's things like
controlling the volume,
skipping track, muting or
pressing the voice button.
So when we can use
these buttons, that
helps to provide a more
seamless experience to the user,
helps to reduce learning
costs, and reduce confusion
so that when the driver
steps into the car,
he or she doesn't have
to guess or relearn.
They can just start using
it and it just works.
And more than
integrate it, we also
have to adapt to the different
technologies inside the car.
So if you go to
the dealer today,
you'll find that
technology widely
varies across manufacturers,
makes, and models.
And we need to be able to
provide a solution for those.
So in the screen
that you see, we
need to have a solution
not only for touchscreen,
but we need a solution for--
let's see if it switches,
there we go-- for when
it's not a touchscreen,
so when it's a
rotary knob or maybe
it's a touchpad or some
other interaction method that
hasn't yet been released.
So this gets to be
supremely challenging.
And ultimately, what we see
is that this field is only
getting more complex.
You have different screen sizes.
And those screens
are now-- you're
seeing different form factors.
So some are doing long portrait.
Some are stretching
wide in the landscape.
You have different
control types, of course.
And the layouts for
where technology
is going inside the
car is also changing.
So you're seeing shifts of where
information conventionally used
to be just in the
instrument cluster or just
in the head unit.
You're now seeing migration
of where information is moving
across the inside of the car.
And basically, this is
a lot of complexity.
It's a huge amount
of complexity,
but it's really important
that we pay attention
to this complexity so that you
as developers and designers
and makers don't have
to worry about it.
GERMAN BAUER: Yeah, I want
to iterate on that point.
I think that what
Greg just showed
is that you can go outside
to look at some of the cars
and the differences in
screen sizes and all that,
but you don't have
to worry about this.
Because one of the
things that we're doing,
we're translating the UI
across these different input
and output devices.
And of course as designers,
we could say, whoa, these guys
are crazy.
Why are they doing this?
We want a uniform UI and this
should all be the same, right?
But when you look at cars,
they're very expensive.
They're very
emotional purchases.
People pay a lot of
money for their stuff.
And brand differentiation is
really their competitive edge.
And they're doing
this because they
want to leapfrog each other.
They want to say,
we are this brand
and this is our characteristics.
And our system
basically owes them
to adapt and integrate
well with that system
and be a natural part, as
Greg was showing before.
It needs to feel like
it's part of that system.
And so the good news is
that Android Auto really
takes care of that as far
as apps and services are
concerned, so you didn't have
to be an automotive expert.
And one of the other
interesting challenges
is that as an ecosystem, of
course, we're in many countries
and Android Auto rolls
out to many countries.
And there are many different
locales, regulations, but also
driving habits-- left side,
right side driving and things
like that that all have
to be taken into account.
So when you look at
this overall complexity,
it's actually a pretty
multi-dimensional problem,
where on one side you have
an ecosystem of all apps
and services that all want
to get on Android Auto.
On the other side, you have
many different cars and form
factors.
And in the middle, you have
many different locales where
these products will be used.
That's hard, right?
But the good news is,
again, is that Android Auto
put many, many people hours
into engineering components
that can be reused across
these different form factors.
So hopefully, as a maker
of apps and services,
you are shielded from
that kind of complexity.
And so this speaks to the
point that I was just making.
Basically, the common
platform is important
because we can't
ask you to create
an application or
different application
or design for every
different car type out there.
That would be nearly impossible.
And so we're trying to help
with the standardization
across these things.
And so finally as
designers of the system,
we have a lot of responsibility.
So first, to you guys,
the developers and makers
of things, the apps continue
to work on the system
no matter what future car UI
configuration the manufacturers
will come up with.
And then finally to
the driver, that they
get to use their stuff,
their content on all
these different cars and doing
so in a responsible manner.
And then finally, to
the car manufacturer,
that they get an
ecosystem of apps
that they can use to augment
their car experience.
GREG NEISWANDER: As
German just mentioned,
we have this responsibility
to the driver.
And part of that
responsibility is understanding
that humans simply aren't as
capable inside the car when
they're driving.
We're just not as good at
interacting with technology,
because we have this competing
safety critical activity
that we have to
pay attention to.
So we have to be very
careful and weigh things
very carefully,
every design decision
against the implications of
the effects and the effects
that it might have
on human performance.
And there's this
critical balance here.
Essentially, one of the
cruxes of really developing
experiences inside the
car is, how can you
deliver a positive
user experience
while at the same
time making sure
that we're not
overtaxing the driver?
And that leads us to
this very typical process
of research and design.
So this is a pretty
common iterative cycle
that you see in most
development cycles.
But I point it out
because it's really
absolutely critical for our team
to have this close hand in hand
process.
And we really overly
invest in research,
in our research
because distraction
is such a critical issue.
So we need this tightly coupled
process between the two,
because it really helps
to facilitate rapid design
and helps us to head in the
right direction early on,
rather than having to
course correct later
on when it's more costly.
And that leads us more or less
to trying to test everything.
So a lot of the principles
and the patterns
that you see from
Android Auto aren't
a random set of
ideas and theories
that we've just arrived on.
They're the result of a
highly intuitive process
that's predominantly led by
vast amounts of user testing.
So we rigorously test again
and again, as much as we can.
And we have a lot
of tools and methods
that we use, both on
the qualitative side
and the quantitative side.
But rather than dwell on this
slide, I'll go to the next one.
So we have this quick
video which is Nat and Lo.
Is anybody familiar
with Nat and Lo?
A few people.
So Nat and Lo is
this YouTube channel.
It's a couple Googlers
that go around Google
and they film behind the scenes
action of different projects
and things happening at Google.
And then they post it on
their YouTube channel.
So they recently
stopped by Android Auto
to check out our research lab.
I'm not going to
play the whole clip,
but I recommend everybody
go and check that out.
But instead, I have some quick
clips that I'll talk over.
So we can go ahead
and play the video.
And this is just to show some
of the different research
activities that we do.
So there's their start up.
And then there's Nat and Lo.
It's really Lo and
Nat, in that order.
So we have driving simulators.
So this is one of our
driving simulators.
And basically what you see
is it's a representation
of a car inside of our lab.
And it allows us to put
participants inside a fake car,
but give them this really
immersive environment
as they drive.
And as they do this, we'll
give them tasks in Android Auto
to perform.
And so as they try and drive
and complete tasks, we then
look at their
driving performance
and evaluate, how much
does their driving
performance degrade?
And that's an indicator
of if we need to redesign
or not if something's
overly distracting.
Beyond the simulator, we
look at eye tracking as well.
So as I mentioned before, visual
distraction is really critical.
So here's one of
our eye trackers.
It of course tracks the eye.
And it gives us a quantitative
assessment of natural glance
behavior inside the car.
So we use this, again,
paired with the simulator
to have them engage with
tasks in Android Auto
as they have to also drive.
And that helps us to determine
how people make glances.
And if we find that people have
to make too long of glances,
that's an indicator that
it's overly distracting
and we need to go
back and redesign.
And we also look at
cognitive measurement.
This is a little bit
harder to assess.
But this is detection
response task, DRT.
And basically, she's putting
a microswitch on her finger.
That's a little button
that she can click.
Then she also has a
tactor that gets taped.
We tape it around the neck area.
And that vibrates on
a random interval.
And when she feels
the vibration,
she has to acknowledge
it with the button.
And basically, this is
a really rudimentary way
to black box the brain
and look at the phase
delay of cognitive processing.
We can start to evaluate,
relative to other tasks, how
distracting something is
from the cognitive aspect.
Then we have occlusion goggles.
These are these really
goofy-looking goggles.
And they cycle between fully
opaque and fully transparent.
And it's just a really
quick, easier way
to simulate a dual task
environment for evaluating
whether a task can be completed
within a reasonable time
and whether or not
a task is chunkable.
GERMAN BAUER: Thanks, Greg.
That was really great.
We have a little time left
to talk about implications
for the future in the
areas we're interested in,
in terms of future.
And also you can't
have a presentation
about cars without talking
about the future, I guess.
We're really at the beginning
of this journey, where we're
starting to understand
that bringing two
industries together
from the internet
and develop a community and
maker of apps and Google,
and on the other side the
automotive industry, which
has much longer development
cycles between car cycles,
sometimes seven years and more.
But really understanding
the thoroughness
that they put into the
process is actually essential,
because they're
building huge machinery.
It's actually a very
non-trivial problem.
And at the same time,
they're learning from us
as we're going through more
rapid iterations of things.
And both of these
things coming together
is starting to be a
really interesting mix
and a new potential
for developing things
that weren't here yet before.
And we are starting to see also
that the automotive [INAUDIBLE]
that we're building,
we're starting
to apply those to other
areas within Android,
because we are having some
very interesting learnings.
One area that we want to
look at in the near future
is that we're very interested in
new types of applications that
haven't yet been
covered, where there's
innovative areas like car
health, driving monitoring,
new forms of car ownership, or
even professional drivers that
require new types of apps.
So in this case, for
example, an EV manufacturer
might be really
interested in talking
about how their batteries are
doing and things like that.
So we're starting to think
about apps in the car
also as something that
goes over to Android
as morphable apps,
morphable systems that
can take different shapes.
And that's something
we're learning
as we're building Android Auto
that might apply to future
in other form factors,
different shapes
depending on what the
context is and what
your cognitive ability is.
And so this is something
that is completely new.
Another thing that I love
about designing for cars
is that it's really sort
of a greenhouse, a very
defined environment.
Everything has its place.
It's very heavily constrained.
And so we can start
experimenting and learning
from things as people are
sitting in this position.
There's clearly a
driver, a passenger,
maybe passengers in the back.
They all have their roles.
And so we're
starting to learn how
we organize the system optimized
for these specific roles.
And we can do this
in a car much better
than we can do this in
freeform environment
like the phone or the TV.
Another area that we're
very interested in
is thinking beyond just
the in-cabin experience.
Because when you think about it,
as Greg was mentioning before,
there's really a
pre-drive experience
and there's a post-drive
experience that's
very important to
us, that really
makes this the whole
holistic experience.
But also think of
it as a scale thing.
You have your phone.
But your phone is inside a
car, which has multiple phones.
And then the car drives inside
an interconnected system
of cities and highways.
And each presents a new
connected opportunity
to innovate in.
One example is that
for example in Maps,
you see the green,
red, yellow of traffic.
And this is something where
small units of information
get put together to form
useful information for all
the drivers.
And we believe that every
major change in transportation
has fundamentally changed
the infrastructure.
Trading notions of scale, the
way we build and the way we
organize our cities.
And we believe that this next
thing, the connected entities
that cars are, will change
that yet once again.
And cars-- it's
interesting, because when
we look at 10 years ago, cars
were really super optimized.
They had the engine optimized
and all this other stuff.
But as people are using
phones in different ways
and people are using
connectivity in different ways,
they have, as Greg
pointed out, expectations
of how they can also
use this in the car
as they're spending more
and more time in the car.
And so this is very clear that
this is a brand-new platform.
And we think about computing
in a very different way.
And so as we think about this,
it's become very clear to us
that cars, connected cars, do
become a thing unto themselves.
In the past, when mobile
phones first came out,
people tried to shoehorn the
PC interfaces into mobile
by just shrinking it.
It was a bad idea.
So the phone has come a long way
to develop its own interface.
And real change will
happen to the car UIs.
They're not just
smartphone interfaces
that are a little bit
blown up, but they
will happen as cars become
their own connected thing
in themselves.
And so we're almost at
the end of this talk.
And if you remember only
two things from this talk,
we want you to take away this.
First thing is, we really
learn that we needed
a completely different
model for the UI
to get design for
driving optimized.
And the second thing
is that Android
as an operating system, and
specifically Android Auto,
helps you with building
some of this expertise
directly into the
building blocks you get
to use for making applications.
And this is a long process.
Because of all the safety and
driver destruction implication,
we have to very thoroughly
test all this stuff.
But the future is very exciting.
We as an operating
system are also
starting to learn to
almost morph and adapt
the UI to new constraints and
to future form factors that we
haven't even thought about.
And believe me, there's
some crazy stuff
out there that we
see at auto shows
where the screen's
like hugely wide.
And normal computing
environment,
normal adaptive responsive
design doesn't even follow this
and wouldn't have
a response to that.
So we're only at the
beginning of this evolution.
And we see this as
the starting point.
And we can wait to see what
together, you and us, will
build from this going forward.
Thank you very much for coming.
GREG NEISWANDER: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]